10  the three nominees for the 2022 lux  audience award have been announced  flea is an animated documentary telling  the true story of amin an afghan refugee  who came to denmark alone as a teenager  now years later he confronts a secret  from his past  great freedom takes place in post-war  germany when homosexuality was a crime  hands is put in prison for being gay  while there a relationship slowly  develops between him and his cellmate  victory  [Music]  [Music]  ida works as a translator for the united  nations in srebrenica which has recently  been invaded by serbian forces her  family is one of hundreds seeking  protection  ida faces a dilemma can she use her  position to help her family and her  people  the winner of the lux audience award is  chosen by the public and members of the  european parliament people all over  europe have until the 25th of may to  vote for their favorite film  you